you
hello everybody and welcome to today's
presentation towards commercial
manufacture of pluripotent stem cell
derived a little piece presented by Rhys
McCallum senior scientist at cell and
gene therapy catapult on our MacDonald
of Thermo Fisher Scientific and I'll be
your moderator for today's presentation
before we begin I'd like to remind you
that this is this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions you may have at
any time during this presentation just
click on ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
and type your question into the drop
down box that appears on the screen will
answer as many questions as we have
claimed for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please use
the ask a question box to let us know of
any technical difficulties
so now please allow me to introduce Rhys
McCowan Rhys McCallum of ph.d is a
senior scientist and the process
industrialization team at cell and gene
therapy catapult Yuki Rhys and a BS RBE
honours and chemical and process
engineering at the University of
Canterbury in New Zealand before
starting his career with a PhD and
biochemical engineering and professor
Nicholas Sita's group at University
College London there he designed and
tested a microfluidic system for the 2d
edeliant culture of pluripotent stem
cells with fine control over the micro
environment since joining cell and gene
therapy catapult in 2014 this has been
continually active on fee-for-service
collaborative and core funded projects
developing pluripotent stem cell based
processes and has played a leading role
in exploring the 3d expansion of of
pluripotent stem cells as aggregates
so now I'll turn the presentation over
to him
for the very kind introduction and good
morning good afternoon and good evening
to everyone listening in around the
world as Anne said I'll be presenting on
our work towards the commercial
manufacture of turbine stem cell derived
therapies but first and briefly I
promise there'll be a couple of slides
on who the southern gene therapy
catechol are virtually in relation to
this talk then why we're interested in
proponent stem cell derived therapies
and major barriers to their commercial
manufacture before getting into what
we've been doing to address these
barriers and what our plans are going
forward
so first anyone who is unfamiliar who
are the 17th replicatable
17 therapy telephone is part of a
world-leading network of technology and
innovation centers we were established
in 2012 as a non-profit independent
center by the UK government through
innovate UK
we aim to accelerate commercialization
of research and growth of the cell in
gene therapy industry through
collaborative innovation providing
access to unique expertise and
facilities and working with policy and
practice makers to create a fantastic UK
environment in which the cell and gene
therapy sector can flourish
here in goes through and London we have
established 1200 square meters of
state-of-the-art development
laboratories and we also have a
dedicated viral vector industrialization
laboratory which allows us to
investigate availability cost and
scale-up of viral vectors
slightly further north and Stevenage we
have a large-scale GMP manufacturing
center which allows companies to develop
their large-scale GMP and commercial
manufacturing processes in collaboration
with challenging therapy catapult and
benefiting from end-to-end expertise and
practical support from our experts
and indeed our most unique and important
asset is the team of over 170 cell and
gene therapy specialist based across
those two locations we between them have
expertise and process industrialization
so that's my team regulatory and
clinical development and various
engagement activities
so one of our strategic priorities for
the next five years and indeed the most
relevant today's presentation is
intelligent manufacturing here we are
working with therapeutic developers
contract manufacturing and service
organizations and the supply chain to
develop new technologies intelligent
systems and automation to increase
productivity and reduce cost of goods so
as to confer both technological and cost
advantages to industry and to reduce the
reliance on labor-intensive processes
but this schematic shows one way of
illustrating this approach by presenting
for progressive phases of automation we
start on the left with manual processes
which are typically well established but
open labor-intensive
operated dependent and generally higher
risk first step towards automation
involves using multiple pieces of
automated equipment sequence to deliver
the various processing unit operations
applicable to the process in question
this should result in a closed process
with increased reproducibility and
robustness and also provides the
opportunity to bolt on process control
systems with the same modular approach
next step is to link pieces of equipment
together into an integrated system
resulting in increased containment and
efficiency reduced labor and allow for a
more integrated process control strategy
finally we think we see that there's an
opportunity for a step change from that
integrated approach of manufacturing a
single batch we higher throughput
systems and predictive process control
and doing that further decreasing the
footprint and reducing costs so the key
message and objective here is there as
process become more automated the cost
of bits are reduced and the potential of
just realization increase
okay
and that's where today's topic comes in
why open stem cell drive therapies
we all know all cell or gene modified
cell therapies can be split into one of
two categories or tolerance analysis and
a Republican therapies use your own
cells which are taken and a biopsy or a
blood collection manipulated through
selection expansion and differentiation
and/or gene modification and then
administered that you
each patient has their own cell source
and each therapy for each patient is
produced in parallel and because it's
their ownselves the patient's immune
system should expect the sellers without
any immune rejection
in contrast an allergenic therapy the
cells come up from somebody else there
again manipulated through selection
expecting differentiation and/or gene
modification and then administered
through multiple in patients because
they're from someone else you can use
the same source of multiple patients you
can make product for all of them in the
same batch
however because there's someone else's
cells that is the increased possibility
of the product cells and the patient
cells having an immune response and
attacking each other
in contrast to autologous therapies
Alexander therapies can be manufactured
and advanced stated once the patient
need to them this means they can be made
available off the shelf and administered
as soon as the need arises which is
particularly important for trauma or
acute conditions like cube myocardial
infarctions or stroke for example
advanced manufacturing also means that
failure of a batch is less likely to
directly impact patients relative to an
autologous equivalent where it may not
be possible to complete a new batch
furthermore telegenic therapy schools
will be less invasive patients than or
talos equivalents as a know collection
of starting material from the patient is
required it could be important
considering the patient is very unwell
and may struggle to endure the
collection process
then or from the process side because
the best are patient-specific
larger betters should be possible which
reduces the potential to use established
biopharma technologies such as stirred
tank reactors possibility to scale up
rather than scale out processes to
introduce lower cost of goods through
economies of scale
so to finish my case for alginate
therapy's I'd like to consider a generic
autologous therapy example in our
experience autologous therapies take
from less than seven to over sixty days
to produce but let's in this one is ten
days long let's assume that the process
fits on a compact all-in-one system with
a busy lap start when you see if you're
patient material studied at the end when
you formulate and fill your product
well a ten days processing time per
batch and allowing something around time
between batches should be able to
produce eighteen batches per units per
year
now we take a market size that was
estimated for one of our projects we
would require more than 190 parallel
units to produce this product to meet
market demand
and if we assume that each suite and our
new manufacturing since that could
support about 16 units in parallel we
would need 1 full manufacturing center
make this one product the Google Maps
was not updated when I downloaded
structure that that blue box is the
rough footprint of our manufacturing
center located at Stevens even inch next
to the bio slab catalyst in this case I
however if we consider a larger
indication another project we worked on
estimated amount of size approximately
thirty-five thousand patients yeah but
now we're talking greater than 1,900
parallel systems and Rock Symphony ten
manufacturing centers produce a single
product but we've become quite a large
occupy o space leave image in contrast
our estimates for an optimized Ella
genetic process for that project
predicted you would need approximately
half of one of our manufacturing centers
manufacture for that market size just
shows what sort of contrast you can get
in the scale and the space required to
deliver the same market
so with an elegant white develop
troponin stem cell derived therapies
potential sources of cells Allison a
therapy include somatic cells such as
mesenchymal stem cells those like t-cell
modified éxito to reduce the risk of
immune response model a ourselves and
the program stem cells that we have
chosen as the exemplar begin our
development
themselves by definition can
differentiate juice almost any cell type
of the adult body they can also divide
indefinitely to produce more and more
apparent cells both 2d and 3d processes
have been demonstrated for through bonus
names of expansion and differentiation
and it's the combination of properties
that give turbulance themselves their
immense potential as starting material
for cell therapies which drove our
choice as to where the star development
whoa
I haven't listened to my case for them
you may be asking why aren't we all
already using programs themselves arrive
therapies
indeed in our non clinical and clinical
trial reports for the UK so non-focal on
their pre clinic on the left and
clinical trials on the right our genetic
therapies make up approximately half of
preclinical trials in just one third of
clinical trials why is that well first
of all what topic is therapy sometimes
do make sense particularly when the
market size is small shelf life is low
and the risk of immune rejection is high
but further to the advantages we've
already discussed ozonate therapies also
face some significant challenges the
first and foremost safety as mentioned
earlier there is potential for immune
response different groups around the
world are currently working for mitigate
this through HLA matching by donor
selection so Universal donors or cell
line engineering to create immune
evasive cells
and depending on the therapy the
mechanism of action is not always fall
under stood which can present challenges
setting up a target product profile and
it also always the concern at the
potential for to merge Anisa t
particularly when starting with cells
self renew indefinitely and when
expanding cells for expensive areas
beaver art in vitro
but then looking at the manufacturing
processes current processes are often
open manual involved animal products and
sarin and has limited assays established
for monitoring and control these factors
make process is inefficient and
unreliable is to say expensive
challenging from a regulatory point of
view and impractical to scale up to meet
market demand just to put things back in
perspective remember that when programs
themselves have been grown historically
within dishes and flasks some coatings
made from animal products whose
composition wasn't known and was
variable called camellia containing
serum who gains accomplish and what
aestivum known as variable and when they
ran out of space and their plate or in
their flasks
they were passage into the next by
manually scraping to generate clumps of
just the right time and not what you
would call an industrialized core
process
and unfortunately the scale required
rather large but even assuming that
relevant differentiation process can
achieve a year 100 set the manufacturing
volume to expand list your opponents
themselves very very very large so there
is a clear need for robust efficient
scalable processes many mastectomy mark
that's my little sales pitch so what are
we here at 17:30 head about breathing
about it
well this is the strategy we've taken
and setting out to address them by
developing those close to automated
efficient and scalable platform
processes our strategy includes the
generation of embryonic and induced
pluripotent stem cell banks adapted to
defined industry-standard culture
systems and characterized to industry
standards exploring parameters to
increase the efficiency of both 2d and
3d programs in cell culture scaling up
both 2d and 3d PC culture investigating
systems to harvest concentrate and wash
those programs themselves I'm appending
all of that developing an analytical
framework relevant assays and
measurements can analyze them direct
approaches there's all of this will
result in platform processes assays and
development approaches that can be
leveraged for different programs stem
cell drive there
so we work with two exemplars sources of
burping stem cells the chef 6.1 line a
human embryonic stem cell line kindly
donated by the UK stem cell back
and our CIB tan line an IPS IPS line
that was the precede of lot of which we
derived under GMP conditions that is a
research grade banks and the research
grade IPS Bank has been distributed to
external collaborators globally who have
collectively demonstrated
differentiation potential to cells of
all three germ layers
in house we have tested more than 10
reagent systems for 2d s expansion we
have characterized cell banks adapted
from either the human embryonic or the
induced troponin starting material and
we generated protocols for standard 2d
culture and analytical assays for
quality testing and characterization
since both safety and identity but here
you see examples across the top right of
morphology and growth rate in the middle
row of phenotype by flow cytometry and
you know staining differentiation for
the three germ layers are shown in the
bottom left by immunostaining and on the
bottom row we also have gene expression
profiles and measures of ecology so this
is the level of characterization we're
applying to those banks that we interact
then looking at to the expansion we have
explored parameters fatuity culture
ourselves and through a number of
collaborations investigating different
culture media messaging agents and
extracellular matrices
we and when we do these investigations
again we investigate growth rates and
viability quality metabolism protein
expression by flow and expression by
qPCR so here in the top right we have a
forget comparing growth in six different
media and on the bottom row we have a
study of different combinations of media
and 2d coating material nature and
growth rate morphology and expression of
protein matter specialists
we have also investigated different
medium exchange regiment so these two
figures from the same experiment the
bottom right shows the concentration of
metabolic waste product at the end of
each day of culture and as you can see
there's relatively little difference
between different feeding regimen
however when you look at the top plot
where it shows viability and viable cell
density you can see this is a very
significant difference in the final
viable so density achieves with these
different region
then when it comes to to the scale up
our approach has focused on a hollow
fiber bioreactor the quantum from rumor
in the hollow fiber system the cells
grow inside the wall thousands of tiny
fibers and medium can be circulate both
inside and outside with small molecule
was able to diffuse across the wall of
those fiber
now this provides 2.1 square meters of
culture surface and the system with a
relatively small footprint I think more
importantly the hollow fiber system
allows you to continuously replace
medium control gas exchange resulting
them more controls culture environment
itself
the hollow fiber system is achieving
high cell density and recovering the
cells of those higher cells entities
however we've found that we were able to
seed at lower densities than we
typically use in flasks and we're still
able to achieve similar fold expansion
number
we see here so metabolic measurements
have allowed us to predict the cell
number relatively accurately in a system
where it's not possible to image or
sacrifice wealth for example so this
plot on the left the hollow triangles
are showing the predicted cell yield
based on developed measurements and then
the solid triangle at the end was the
actual harvest yield
we've developed the process shown here
where population doublings cell
viability and media consumption and are
reproducible and favorable in comparison
with plastic sculpture as you see in the
two top right clock
and experiments so far indicate they're
using the hollow fiber relative to 2d
plastic wear and reduce cost of goods by
45 percent reduce labor by two-thirds
and increase facility throughput by 250
percent you can see it's not just about
closing and automating that you do get
significant return in terms of savings
and throughput
then looking at the 3d sides our initial
approach to 3d expansion has been to
investigate aggregate based expansion
from single cell seating with periodic
sibling to allow for the medium exchange
so you see here across the bottom some
examples of extent expanding referencing
so aggregates over the course and
experiment the process tremors we
initially explored or explored at 15
mill scale on the amber 15 system that
should top right does this have either
24 or 48 fitted tank reactors operating
in parallel
and at 150 ml scale and the deathlok
system which is a bottom right which has
four parallel SDI units the controller
system
and the parameters we've explored
Impella speeds feeding regimen and
starting cell concentration again while
measuring by building growth aggregate
size metabolites and expression through
quota but in the top right on the slide
we have a figure showing viability and
viable cell density with three different
feeding regimen and again you can see
the feeding regimen really has a
significant impact on the final viable
so NCATS
and then in the bottom right we have a
contour plot of maximum population
Dublin's achieved or different impeller
speeds feeding Nessa tees and that plots
from a model v to experiments conducted
at different combinations of LSD and sea
helping us narrow down the design space
in which we want to work and then here a
couple more figures so the top right is
profiles of two different satellites
again and the derma investigating
different Needham exchange regiment and
in the bottom right we have example of
image segmentation of a picture that
aggregates so we regularly take samples
and imaged aggregates and then use image
analysis to determine the aggregate mean
size and distribution
so we have we have used the results of
small-scale experiments and engineering
parameters of different vessels to scale
the expansion first 250 mils and then up
to 1.5 liter scale and in doing so we've
demonstrated the scalability of an
aggregate based expansion process from
from 15 mils to 1.5 liters as shown in
the pop net and we have achieved over 3
billion cells at the 1.5 liter scale
that was produced made maintain
expression of through potency markers by
flow cytometry and still demonstrate
potential to differentiate to the three
germ layers for that shown here with
staining for markets of each of the
three germ layer
and again our initial expansion process
achieves similar populations of links to
2d flower sculpture with reduced minion
consumption per cell produced and cost
of goods modeling here indicate that
this SDR process would again deliver
significant reductions in labor and
costs per billion cells as well as a
significant increase in your facility
throughput
I have never mentioned that
however we feel that there's the
potential to further reduce those costs
and increase those throughputs
through intensification as well as
potential to close and automate the
whole 3d expansion project
so we've begun investigating different
cell retention systems both to enable
closed and automated cell passage and to
facilitate medium exchange so on the
right are some images of a trial we did
associating aggregates in the vessel at
the end of an expansion and replacing
the dissociation agent with fresh media
and it closed an automated way using a
TFS approach and we were then able to
get yields after passage comparable to
our reference material as our reference
process of manual centrifugation
we have been testing other technologies
for concentration of wash whether it be
to remove pathogen agent as shown there
or Tanjung from expansion to the
differentiation medium or before and
after other processing steps such as a
selection process or transduction I'm
going to talk about the fluidized bed
centrifugation technology Kasich and
LoVo a spinning membrane filtration
technology but there are other
technologies in our investigation
pipeline such as a DFS and acoustic
filtration for example
so Cape is a fluidized a centrifuge
liquid is pumped towards the center of a
spinning rotor and so is a trapped and a
fluidized bed with opposing forces of
fluid flow and centrifuge are balanced
so to improve recoveries and viability
using this equipment we have
investigated the information flow rate
and information time right as well as
the process flow rate shown in the
bottom right and the wash flat rate and
so far with the cases where the chief
recovery is greater than 80% when
concentrating Washington
[Music]
lova on the other hand is the spinning
membrane technology so it's cycled cells
past the rapidly spinning cylindrical
membrane and it takes advantage of the
resulting hydrodynamics to help prevent
filter clogging and among the parameters
within the investigating here the filter
spin rate and the starting concentration
of cells and bead material so we have
again 2d maps shown on the right here
one for cell viability and one to sell
recovery and so far again with the
louver we've achieved recoveries greater
than 80 okay
to what impacts open factors this all
has well these two figures are from
failure mode and effect analysis and
exercise in which a group of subject
matter experts systematically identify
the score risks based on severity of
impact likelihood of occurrence and
probability of detecting the problem the
plot on the left is for a complete and
manual process so 2d culture and flasks
followed by 3d culture and shape last
figure on the right for an automated
process utilizing a hollow fiber system
followed by a stirred tank reactor where
harvest and wash using a fluidized bed
centrifuge you can see that while some
risks remain the number is greatly
reduced especially of the highs of
critical categories of these are things
that I very likely to go wrong and very
likely have a severe impact on the
process and particularly down here where
we get into the passenger end of the
city culture the 3d expansion and the
harvest concentrate watch which are
other areas that are particularly
addressed by the slides of the standard
so this is just emphasize what what
large impacts these these automating and
closing activities can have on the risk
profile your process
now addition to all the process
development I've talked about running in
parallel with in developing a new
analytical framework and a key objective
of this has been to reduce quality
assessments based on operated judgment
but they're so hard to replicate and
tech transfer and so reliant on having
retaining key skilled staff member
so to that end we've been implementing
image analysis algorithms to extract
confluence and texture from images of 2d
cultures which I'm sure most of the
listeners are familiar to doing
themselves as well as to extract the
aggregate size distribution from 3d
cultures here on the right some
illustrations showing how an intro B
approach makes mix calculation or
conference much easier than which doing
a brightness threshold and you can see
at the bottom there how the algorithm
has picked out the outline of our 3d
cultures very nicely then the the
reproducible and quantifiable metrics
such as the output to be an algorithm
can then be compared with other outputs
which is wandering on a right missus
illustrating such as flow cytometry cell
density to identify target profiles for
different processes which then feed them
through a monitor and control state
another piece of analytical development
that we've been doing is developing a
more cost-effective
qpcr essays and the commercial kit we
had been doing so our in-house sae uses
but if your jeans and much smaller
sample volume than the commercial kit we
have reason but the litters similar gene
expression profiles across all those
things where overlap
and then again on the analytical side
we've been analyzing the concentration
of different metabolites and medium
components by a variety of techniques
which includes
lc/ms and Raman spectroscope in again on
the top right we have a figure showing
the stability of a particular medium
component three different temperatures
which informs on our line you can have
it sitting out on the bench for example
before you edit your system and then how
long it's going to be present in your in
your culture on the bottom right we have
the concentration of a molecule at the
end of each day of culture across three
different passages and in the bottom
left we have the concentration of the
molecule after six days of four
different processes we've got apse
expansion directive differentiation
ectoderm endoderm and commutative
correlation of different soluble
compounds with process parameters and
outcome we think really offers a great
potential to identify novel non-invasive
methods of process control
I'm going to move now from what we've
always been doing to what we want to be
doing going forward look if I don't jump
in looks like that's what
so our goals in the next couple of years
include further intensification of the
3d expansion process that's something
attached upon we want to keep keep
increasing the yield we can achieve
using with the natural processes
we want to demonstrate further scaler of
both the current and intensified
expansion processes so we may go up to
one and a half liters so far that we
would like to keep scaling further
we want to translate exemplar
differentiation processes to the 2d and
3d and automated systems that was
discussed after expansion and then in
terms of enabling real-time monitoring
and adaptive control we want to further
characterize PFC expansion and
differentiation processes we want to
identify and develop assays for
surrogate quality markers that was what
I was just referring to for example with
the measures of metabolites and we want
to bring the focus onto that early
germline differentiation which will be
the most universally translatable to any
process that collaborated my contract
with finally we're assessing novel
materials and technologies to increase
productivity and reduce the cost of
large-scale processing an example here
different novel
micro carrier technologies
the end goal against reiterate is
processes essays with development
approaches that can be leveraged or any
PSC derived products the deliberate
controlled and reproducible automated
and scalable process that can get
people's products through to let face
Clint clinical trials and commercial
manufacture
okay so wrap up the thank-yous a big
thank you to all of the team members who
were involved in producing the work I've
shown to you today and into all of the
different companies and institutions
we've collaborated with over the past
five years a big THANK YOU to
semi-official
for inviting me to talk to you all today
and finally thank you to everyone for
for listening it that's me
don't thank these for that informative
presentation so when I'm going to begin
the live question-and-answer portion of
the webinar so if you still get a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now by clicking on the ask a question
drop-down box located in the far left of
your presentation window take a question
in the box that appears on your screen
and click the sames button now we've
already had a number of questions
already so our first question is when
will stem cell therapy be actually
available as a treatment
- - patience
I mean that there are already cell
therapies on the market there are stem
cell therapies in clinical trials famous
famously retinal retinal disease
so I mean my impression is that we're
not far away from seeing the things and
start to roll out and to market
I think the first players will be for
smaller indications and you know that
the eye is particularly attractive
target because it's a new privilege I
think for larger scale larger markets
and less immune privileged implications
probably looking at
two or three years from my perspective
before we start seeing a really growing
market but they are they are there in
clinical trials now and it's just a
question of how quickly those clinical
trials can can find patients and how
quickly we can address these processing
issues that I've discussed today and
what we are trying to do from the
process industrialization point of view
is make sure that it's not the
processing that's the limiting factor to
getting them to market
Thanks so we have a question which I
think relates to early on in your
presentation who you were discussing
towards intelligent manufacturing where
you had mentioned for manual processing
was open but also high-risk and so we've
got a question which says what do you
mean by high-risk exactly can you please
elaborate a little bit more yeah okay so
obviously if you have an open process it
is a higher R it is not guaranteed but
it is a higher risk of contamination
which is something we will want to avoid
but also in terms of of manual
processing because it's because it's a
person doing it you're you're always
running the risk of variation both
operator to operator and even variation
and that operators performance day to
day in minute to minute and you know
what we see we still see processes that
have scraping or protecting it just the
right speed and just the right number of
times processes where you have to
achieve a uniform self suspension by
manually mixing
and it's very very easy to introduce a
lot of variability there which then
depending on where it is in the process
translates product variability and
whether or not that variability is that
acceptable to pass on to the patient is
going to be specific to the process then
therapy but just getting away from
operator judgment and operator dependent
steps will really reduce the the risk of
your process being unsafe or ineffective
so lots of more questions coming in here
so let me just go back and so someone's
also asked about you mentioned our
genetic and under looking for a look but
more understanding of what does that
mean
does allogeneic refer to and the stem
cell or any cell that will be later used
to modify into the and pluripotent stem
cell so I guess they mean the donor cell
that as you programmed so far out
perhaps you could just do a little
definition of Elul versus Auto yeah so
Auto autologous is where the starting
cell material comes from the eventual
patient so better cells might just be
purified or might be expanded they might
have gene modification so they present a
particular surface protein but the key
thing is that the starting cell has come
from patient and therefore HLA type and
all of those proteins involved in
potential immune response should match
the recipient and prompts a immune
response whereas as I said allergenic
you have a donor material typically it's
a cell bank theoretically it could be
primary cells from someone else
but the cells have come from a different
person to the patient
I hope that makes it a bit clearer
absolutely
and then in related to that we have a
question around in our generic apse
therapies would there be more chances of
immunological and so how can we overcome
that again you touched a little bit on
that in your presentation but if you
could expand a little yeah I I'm not
sure the the question is specifically
IPS or clear bone and in general
obviously because the proponents
themselves out from the patient there is
an increased risk of immune response
it's not something that we're heavily
involved in addressing but we are aware
that a lot of groups trying to address
this around the world the two main
approaches that I'm aware of are
selecting donors with an HLA type that
will be accepted by a large portion of
the population so this is similar to
being negative and blood donations
anyone can receive our negative blood if
we can find donors who have an HLA type
that would be accepted by a large
percentage of the population then we
could make therapies from a small subset
of donor materials and be in a position
to treat the majority of creation the
other approach I'm aware of is
genetically modifying cells so that we
either achieve that HLA type which will
be highly accepted or remove the surface
proteins for the most likely to cause
problems altogether again creating a
cell material that should be accepted by
the majority of patients and I know
different groups of pursuing either or
both of those who avenues I think both
have those headstrong potential I would
like to put all my eggs in either basket
at this point
a couple of technical questions no for
the immunohistochemistry can you let us
know what markers you're using to taste
or end of them I'm not a member of
analytic with him I don't know the full
panel so this the slide here was just
showing a single marker and I think that
a layer one was as well
[Music]
so in this case for and that we were
looking at socks even Tina Blake was and
then and then a similar question and was
what what cell lanes should I choose for
checking noodle Jin's expression
sorry could you repeat our what cell
lanes should I use for checking noodle
Jin's expression I wonder whether that's
also what markers should you be looking
for for noodle gene expression yeah I
wouldn't like to answer off the top of
my head hang
coming engineering background that's
something I would always go and research
okay so let me let me bounce back to an
engineering question and we have a
comment I'm asking about is there any
way to look at online monitoring of of
things like cell numbers or do you look
at other types of online monitoring and
as the cells are being expanded
yeah so depending on the system they're
in different different things are
available to us which I showed in the
case of the hollow fiber expansion that
we were monitoring monitoring
metabolites that's currently outline
rather than online in terms of the 3d
systems obviously STRs in a widely used
and are designed for multiple probes so
we have your standard pH do and
temperature measurements but we're also
we've also had Roman probes in there
which is a nice online system and then
there are different different automated
sampling systems which can get you close
to online depending on your guess any
questions obviously a viable cell count
of single cells is on there quite
quickly so automated sampling system can
work for a sample and count single cells
if it requires a dissociation step in
between that will make it more complex
but certainly we we want to include
include online monitoring and through
the current ad line and offline
monitoring we plan to prioritize what
sort of probes we want to put in there
for example there'd be no point looking
at a metabolite that doesn't help inform
process but if there's something that
can tell us that oh you need to ramp up
your medium addition or you need to add
more of this particular growth factor
sooner than you would normally purely by
reading a metabolite or a cytokine then
that would be there with the idea
thank you um another question actually
was what type of sales are you using but
I think we answered that in the
presentation you have your two test cell
lines one the es line from Sheffield the
the chef's line unit sir
and the other one
I had an IPS line that you made a nice
yes okay
I'm someone asking about you know what
kind of what kind of tests that you have
to to do to ensure a clinical trial
safety is that something that you're
involved in or weight off
so we're not that I can think of
currently making any PC Drive stuff
ourselves for clinical trials that were
involved in collaborators who are in
clinical trials
as always as with all these things it's
always a conversation with the regulator
and I was careful earlier in the
presentation to say that a lot of these
less desirable attributes of processes
make things regulatorily challenging
because if you can if you can justify
the need and demonstrate appropriate
controls and safety studies then you can
always make a case to the regulator
there is I believe there will always be
a requirement to show you haven't got
have I got detect all levels of troponin
cells remaining you're differentiated
products and the regulator's have made
suggestions on what markers they're
looking at for there for example the top
three four and they want to show that
you haven't got so is still expressing
or four in your final products depending
on whether your cells have been
activated or not there will be higher or
lower requirements there certainly for
active cells the carry ology is going to
be pretty critical but it is very hard
to draw up a list for a therapy without
knowing what it is and what process it's
been through we always would encourage
people to get regulatory advice
throughout their development and so we
have have a conversation with the
regulator as early as possible
definitely try and start thinking about
what essays you'll need
commercial process before you need them
because the requirements will ramp up as
you progressed through clinical trials
and you don't want to get to the end of
phase 3 and suddenly you need to develop
some assays and have to do more and more
runs to do your sa development you want
to be developing that in parallel with
your clinical trials so you can use that
material for your analytical development
okay we have a question a little bit
future-focused of can you see a future
where an active Oregon might be
completely made by stem cell technology
I would love to see that future I think
that would be an incredible achievement
on on behalf of the whole industry and
many others they're sort of a moon
landing moment where recreating whole
complex organs I know there are exciting
innovations in the field and it's often
often not mentioned because it's seen as
further from the market and it is
further from the market because it's a
more complex endeavor to to both produce
the multiple cell types present in an
organ and then the structure around it
it's coming is going to take us longer
to get there I hope we can obviously
shortage of donor organs as a major
issue I would love to I would love to be
be able to see us get to that point and
even to be involved in it but it is
further away than a therapies based on a
single a single less structured cell
type
so you mentioned the need to remove
important stem cell from the final
product and we have a question here
about is that any risk of oncogenesis
associated with PSC derived allergenic
therapies and I guess the answer is yes
which is why the regulators want to make
sure that you remove that all of the PSC
cells from your final product yeah there
is and I raised it as one of the
barriers it's it's not something that's
entirely processing technology related
it's also the process you going through
obviously if you're starting with a cell
line that can self-renew indefinitely
and produce almost any cell type then if
you put those cells into a person and
there's a chance they can go just that
which we don't want
similarly depending on how much and
where in vitro culture is involved in a
process so the extensive expansion and
differentiation and also how's different
the conditions for that are from what
would occur an usurer
these things can increase the likelihood
of changes mutations that would result
in a malignant malignancy so depending
on depending on again whether your
product is been activated or not there
will be differing differing requirements
to to screen your inner product against
against a risk of tumor in a city
okay in fact thank you I'm partially
we're not going to have time to cover
all the questions that that have been
sent but but just one more given all of
the work that you've been doing with
with all these different processes do
you publish those protocols either
through peer-reviewed journals or on the
catapult website so that people can see
the types of things that you've been
developing
we I don't think we have published meant
any as as many of any of them and we're
working on publishing in journals which
would then obviously have methodology
sections in it and when people approach
us to collaborate via on a grant or
through a fifth service arrangement or
whatever arrangement has worked out with
our business development team that can
include access to the protocols we have
developed obviously we we like to keep
always some nerve Alan I will apologize
because I've been the frustrated person
on the other so the presentation area I
do apologize that I anonymized a lot of
the figures presented and removed
numbers and cell lines and conditions
but obviously we want to hang on to some
no house that we can then share it with
with collaborators so we're not trying
to we're not trying to make it
impossible for anyone to use it we just
would like to do so through some form of
collaboration but yeah as I said we are
working to publish in journalism and
when we do that the methods involved in
what we've been doing will will be part
of those publications
thank you so once again I'd really like
to thank reefers presentation before we
go please know that today's webinar will
be available for on-demand viewing
through to say Billy 2019 so we can
always go back and review the the talk
so thank you again everyone for joining
us Thank You Rhys and thank you to all
the participants who asked questions so
we can get through everything but thank
you very much we hope you enjoy the rest
of today's event
thank you everyone and have a great day
evening night wherever you are
you